[Music]
[Applause]
in just four years 28 year old sidhu
musawala had become a Punjabi hip-hop
Global icon with billions of views and
millions of fans
but a year ago today he was attacked by
gunmen and killed in Punjab
seduce father balcor Singh has chosen to
speak to Sky News about the pain they've
endured since the world lost an artist
and he lost a son
foreign
[Music]
this is where the family stays when in
the UK sidhu's bed and harmonium
untouched
at the local Gurdwara he used to visit
in Gravesend Mr Singh takes me back to
this time last year
simple
foreign
has there been any time for you to heal
instead his family is consumed with
trying to understand why this happened
City's celebrity status meant he
traveled with State security but the new
government publicly announced its
withdrawal the next day he was followed
and killed
it's this timing the family and some MPS
from the UK are questioning there's got
to be a level of accountability that's
exactly what the family is here for they
want Justice from the home of democracy
and they really value the British system
because actually social justice is
integral to us and so they are here
given that their son was had leave to
remain in the United Kingdom asking this
Parliament the mother of all parliaments
to give them Justice
we asked the foreign office for their
response but they said they would not
comment
so far 27 people have been jailed for
playing a part in his murder including
gang members and the investigation is
ongoing but Mr Singh says not quickly
enough
foreign
his son had also gained notoriety as a
politician in recent months this
popularity as a performer was unrivaled
as rap music often does his videos
swaggered on the edge of violence
friends say this was performative
he was attracting worldwide audiences
Rich famous and friends with artists
like Drake and the UK still Bangles
who worked with the star over the years
the ever evolving
youth of today needed someone to be
inspired by so they didn't lose their
cultures whilst in the west and I think
sidhu defined that it's okay to be uh
Punjabi or brown-skinned and in
embracial culture on a on a commercial
level
speak to any fan of Punjabi music and
they'll be able to reel off musi Vala's
full album list that is the level of
popularity we're talking about in just
four years his legacy of asking hard
questions and connecting to his roots
despite much of this community
and in climbing that ladder of Fame he
never forgot his roots
culture
no questions
there's no disputing that we contacted
the Punjab police and state government
regarding the murder investigation but
received no response thousands continue
to mourn a man once called India's most
forceful musical export but at the
center of this celebrity tragedy is
simply a father who just wants answers
in Kent